hey 42 here tennis is a sport enjoyed by
millions around the world
unattended in droves by the rich the
famous and the royals
however it started life as a bunch of
monks
slapping some bulls around with their
hands not those kinds of balls get your
mind out of the gutter
when you think about it sport is pretty
dumb men and women devote their lives to
the rare opportunity
to compete over an utterly meaningless
prize whilst following a set of
ancient arbitrary rules to the adoration
of billions of fans around the world
however some individuals excel at their
sports to
such an insane degree that it defies the
absurdity of sport itself
these aren't your ordinary athletes
these are the athletes
whose achievements are so remarkable
that they make the efforts of their
peers vanish into obscurity
but before we jump in i have a
confession to make
i'm not a man who loves sport truthfully
i rarely watch sport and so making this
video was a
huge learning experience for myself
which i enjoyed immensely
but don't worry i consulted others who
actually know their
striker from their centre-back and yes
i know you all probably have your own
favorite sports stars who you think
definitely deserve a mention here no
questions asked
but unfortunately i just can't make a
video about every famous athlete
in every sport in the spirit of fairness
i'm going to highlight
only those who did the absolute most
to reshape popularize and utterly
dominate their chosen sport also i
decided to stick to sports that were
one popular and two don't involve
vehicles
this was for two reasons the first is
that nobody
not one person on the planet cares
who the best man in the world at curling
is i'm sure even he doesn't care
the second is that skillfully piloting a
vehicle is
very impressive but it's a completely
different ball game than competing with
just your body
and let's face it if i did include
vehicles this entire video would just
become a breakdown of the moto gp
and the isle of man tt and rally because
those guys are out of their goddamn
minds
now let's begin boxing may not be the
most popular sport in the world
but it is able to compel people's
attention like perhaps no other
especially when there's a
once-in-a-generation clash of the titans
such as when dante wilder recently
attempted
to tickle tyson fury to the ground and
he was having none of it
i guess when someone goes around beating
the crap out of everyone
the world tends to take notice mike
tyson is a good example
he entered the scene and knocked his
opponents out so viciously
and decisively that humanity without
hesitation decided he was the baddest
man
on the planet but who is the greatest
boxer
of all time this it turns out
is a highly contentious topic one
debated by boxing experts
all across the world so without
hesitation
i'm going to barge in and offer my not
so enlightened
opinion a lot of pundits believe that
cassius clay
later known as muhammad ali was the
greatest boxer of all time
hell he even called himself the greatest
and he has several astonishing feats to
back this up to name a few
he was the first to win the heavyweight
championship of the world three times
he won 56 fights with 37 knockouts and
suffered five losses
he had arguably the two most famous
fights of all time against joe frazier
and george foreman you know the grill
guy
he transcended his sport to become a
global icon
more than any other man prior or since
well save one man but we'll get to him
he reinvented heavyweight boxing
fighting with speed
grace and rhythm hitherto unseen at that
weight class
he thought at a time when there was only
one heavyweight champion at any time
and defeated all newcomers he fought
during the most talent-rich era in
heavyweight boxing history
he is considered by some to be the most
charismatic man
who's ever lived for almost everyone
across the world
he is the living embodiment of a
champion but
for all his staggering ability and
showmanship
ali wasn't the greatest
sugar ray robinson was fighting from
1940 to 65
robinson was such a dominant
welterweight and middleweight fighter
that he's literally the reason
pound-for-pound rankings exist those
being where sportswriters compared the
abilities of fights across different
weight classes
let's just look at the facts and please
consider that all of these
are true when robinson was an amateur he
won 85 fights and suffered no losses
yes an 85 winning streak 69 of which
were knockouts
40 of which were in the first round
but it gets better in his professional
career which started when he was 19
he had a record of 173 wins with 109
knockouts
he had a 91 fight winning streak he held
both the world welterweight
title and world middleweight title
winning the latter
multiple times he was the first boxer in
history to win a divisional championship
five times so in short he beat the
living crap
out of a lot of people across multiple
weight classes
robinson had complete mastery of his
sport his technical proficiency as a
fighter is regarded by modern critics
to be perfect he could fight as a
brawler a counter puncher or on the
outside with his jab
all with unrivaled speed and accuracy
describing his own style he said rhythm
is everything in boxing and every move
you make starts with your heart
and that's in rhythm or you're in
trouble
and you don't think it's all instinct
if you stop to think you're gone he was
outrageously confident
when he met george costner in the middle
of the ring he said
we better touch gloves because this is
the only round
he then proceeded to knock costner out
in two minutes and 49 seconds
he once saw an incredibly attractive
woman by the pool
and wondering how to spark up a
conversation decided
to push her in she later became his wife
ali himself once hailed robinson as the
king
my master my idol a sentiment repeated
by joe lewis
sugar ray leonard and roberto durran all
contenders for the title of greatest
robinson once dreamed that he was going
to kill his opponent
jimmy doyle in the ring a dream that led
him to back out of the fight before
being convinced
to return by a priest doyle died after
being knocked out in the eighth round
when he learnt doyle had planned to use
his winnings to buy his mother a home
robinson sacrificed his purse for the
next four fights
to fulfill the dead man's wishes
unsurprisingly in all of those
pound-for-pound rankings robinson
is almost always considered the best and
rightfully so
now basketball may be the most uniquely
competitive sport
on the planet you have to be unnaturally
tall capable of jumping absurdly high
have outrageous fitness unfaltering
accuracy
and capable of replicating that day in
day out
across 82 games in a season all against
a melting pot of outstanding
hand-picked cultivated talent but who
amongst all that talent
dominates all of us now i know what
you're thinking
you already know the answer especially
if you've been watching the last dance
on netflix
it's his earnest himself michael jordan
probably the only athlete to rival ali's
fame
michael jordan is widely regarded as the
greatest basketball player
of all time by other great players as
well as journalists and coaches
not just for his ability to fly like
superman through the air
but because he was an incredible
defender playmaker and shooter
he's widely regarded as the best north
american athlete
of all time he's a marketer's wet dream
and helps solidify
nike as the brand it is today he was so
competitive
that when he retired he walked right
into a major league baseball team
as if that was just a normal thing to do
he's a six-time
nba final mvp six-time nba champion
including
two free petes and has 10 all-nba
first team designations oh and he's also
a two-time gold winning olympian
he even has his own crying meme but
whilst he's the greatest many would
argue that pedestal is shared with one
other man
phil jackson jackson is a two-time
nba champion as a player and an 11-time
nba champion as a coach both with the
chicago bulls and the los angeles lakers
making a world record total of 13
as both player and coach sure there are
much better players
on paper but jackson's achievements
are astonishing because good players
rarely become good coaches and the
cursory glance at sports will show you
good coaches are never good players
jackson is the exception to this and
easily one of the greatest coaches
of all time he combined native american
spiritualism with zen
and perfected the triangle offense to
form a coaching ethos and strategy
that underpinned his success helping him
shepherd legendary players like
kobe bryant shaquille o'neal scottie
pippen dennis rodman
and none other than michael jordan
himself
in fact both men's legacies and rise to
all-time greatness
are highly dependent on one another
jordan and jackson were both reliant on
their tenure with the chicago bulls and
two nba champion free pete's to solidify
their legacies
but jordan couldn't have done it without
jackson's unique and dogged coaching
style
and jackson couldn't have done it
without jordan's ability to
single-handedly
dominate and win games by himself
that is why both are the greatest
basketball players
of all time now when all you need is a
ball and
two feet it's no wonder why football has
grown to be the world's most
popular sport kids learn to play it on
the streets
on the beach at the park and carry the
game
and their love of it with them their
entire lives
it's a sport that defines entire nations
and their culture
football is so popular that for the 2018
world cup
3.572 billion people
tuned in to watch that's over half the
world's population
and in a sport as popular as this the
level of skill and competition faced at
the top
is second to none put simply to be great
at football you have to be
exceptional and a once in a generation
talent that's why the best footballers
get paid millions every year to kick
around a dead cow
and there is one brazilian man who's
commonly called
the king of football by both players and
fans
all over the world that man is pele
peli is widely regarded even amongst
modern greats like messi and ronaldo
to be the greatest footballer to ever
lace up the boots
and his achievements a testament to this
he won three world cups
he was voted world player of the century
he's the most successful domestic league
goal scorer in football history scoring
650 goals in 694
league matches and he holds a guinness
world record
for 1 281 goals in 1
363 games including unofficial
friendlies
that's an incredible amount of times
comments has had to scream
unintelligible noises down a microphone
he's also had if legends are to be
believed
an equal number of affairs you also know
you're great when you're known by one
word
just ask prince or jesus pele started
playing for the brazilian national team
at age 16 and from then on averaged
almost
a goal a game he was an incredible
playmaker he could strike from any foot
and was a blend of all the other great
players throughout history
he led like zidane shot like ronaldo
dribbled like nazario
he had it all you know how people say
superman has everyone else's powers
well that describes pele in real life
his ability to finish was merciless and
it was backed up with an unrivaled level
of pace
and balance as well as an explosive
attack
and defensive intelligence people would
travel from all over the world
just to catch a glimpse of him playing
and his creative unpredictable nature
always put on a good show a former
manchester united striker and world cup
winner sir bobby charlton said of him
i sometimes feel as though football was
invented for this magical player
and manchester united defender paddy
crerand
stated that pele's name was spelt g-o-d
and in his own words pele said there
will only be one pele
there won't be anyone else like me i
don't think there will
and due to football's overwhelming
popularity
you could make a compelling argument as
to why pele may just be
the greatest sportsman of all time but
in the spirit of fairness i'd like to
present another option
because being the most popular doesn't
necessarily make something
the greatest you see as beautiful a game
as football is
there's another sport which makes it
look rather
timid a sport that also involves an
albeit oddly shaped ball
running from one end to the other and
teams of over 10 men competing to score
points
but unlike football these men run at
each other
full pelt smash into one another like
human battering grams
and then stamp each other into the dirt
oh and they occasionally grope each
other's bottoms
also many games begin with a
blood-crazed war dance
in fact this sport requires a bit of all
the other sports in this video
combined the brutality violence and
physicality of boxing
the hand-eye coordination and accuracy
of basketball and the coordinated team
elegance of football
i'm speaking of course a rugby
possibly the most physically demanding
sport on earth
it's a sport that requires power
endurance skill
tactical nuance and mental resilience
all whilst being smashed to pieces
by 15 110 kilogram men
with dodgy earlobes it requires immense
reserves of anaerobic
and aerobic fitness whilst putting
players bodies under tremendous amounts
of stress
concussions bloody injuries and torn
ligaments
are not uncommon one player even had his
scrotum torn open
ouch others have died
and this is no surprise just ask one of
your friends even if he's moderately
sized
to tackle you as hard as he can
now imagine doing that for a living over
and over and over again
week in week out there's a reason
american footballers wear body armor
rugby players have no such luxury
their body armor is being a six foot
hairy scottish man
who's built like a brick house and
although there have been efforts to make
the sport as safe as possible
it is still inherently violent and prone
to injury
though i will say off pitch rugby
players are remarkably gentlemen like
and their sportsmanship and camaraderie
is one of the greatest of
any sport it might not be as popular as
football
but to be remarkable in a sport like
rugby
you have to be about as complete an
athlete as
humanly possible with this in mind you'd
think that being the greatest fly half
who ever lived
the highest point scorer in rugby
history a dashing underwear model
and all-around great guy dan carter
would be a shoeing for the greatest
rugby player of all time
but he's not and there are certainly
some england and wales players who could
contend for this accolade
but no we're going to stay in new
zealand because
the title of greatest goes to richie
mccor
growing up in a small valley in the
south island of new zealand richie spent
his time racing around a big farm
playing rugby
doing chores and running up mountains as
you do
during this time he set himself a humble
goal the kind of goal
any kid sets to be an all black but not
just any old black
a great one the all blacks if you don't
know
are new zealand's famous national rugby
team notorious for their exceptional
winning record
relentless style of play and the
intimidating
slightly silly hakka wardance performed
at the start of each match
to become an all black in a rugby mad
country like new zealand
is no easy feat to become a great one
it's close to impossible but richie
achieved it
he didn't just become a great all black
he became the greatest old black
who whoever lived and not only that he
became
their greatest flanker and their
greatest captain too
here's a breakdown of what he achieved
at 148 test matches he is the most
capped rugby player of all time he won
131 out of 148 tests
coming in at an 88 to 89
win percentage only six men have had
more caps than he has wins
without him the all blacks had a winning
percentage of 68
that's a 20 increase in win chance just
from him being on the field
in rpg terms that's a plus 20 dps
increase
for your entire raid team a very good
buff
he captained his nation to two
back-to-back world cup wins
something no other captain or other
nation has ever done
he's the first all black to ever reach
100 test matches
he's the first rugby union player to win
a hundred tests
he won the bledisloe cup ten times won
the tri-nations four times
and the rugby championship three times
he was 20 years old when he first played
for the all blacks
was widely criticized as too young
but won man of the match in his first
game
shutting everyone up he played 61 games
on new zealand soil
and only lost twice the rugby world cup
website has
him number one on all-time tackles at
he is the highest scoring forward in new
zealand history
135 points for those of you that don't
know
forwards don't typically score he won
rugby player of the year
three times a feat rivalled only by dan
carter
but mccaw won it two consecutive years
he's only ever lost to four teams
australia south africa
england and france he's been in the game
for so long that over 130 players made
their all-black debut
whilst he was playing and he did all of
this
in arguably the most violent mainstream
sport
in the world whilst playing in its most
violent position
in fact to understand what richie
accomplished you really have to
understand what a flanker's role in a
rugby match consists of
quite simply a flanker has to tackle the
ever loving out of people withstand
a barrage of players smashing into you
and steal the ball that's pretty much it
flankers compete in rocks and malls and
they do this over and over and over
again
for 80 minutes of violence it's not a
position that supports player longevity
and it's not a position many players
have the physicality to play in
in the words of world cup winning coach
steve hansen
richie is the best door black we've ever
had richie has played
148 matches at flanker which is unheard
of
you put your body on the line every time
you play there
richie had an enormous influence on the
game
making the breakdown where the ball is
in a rook
being one of if not the most important
elements of a rugby game
this change happened because of just how
good he was
at stealing the ball he was so good at
it that he regularly became the target
of foul play
but he never responded in kind only ever
striking someone once
which is when he defended the ref who
was being attacked by a spectator
richard had an almost preternatural
ability to read where the ball was going
to be and
teleport himself to that exact location
then smashed a player that had it
into oblivion alongside this he was a
born leader of men putting in a peerless
work rate on the pitch
that inspired and led his team for
example and
engaging clearly with the referees
winning them over to his side
and testing what he could and could not
get away with
always looking for that competitive edge
and
to cap things off his last ever rugby
match was winning the rugby world cup
final
at twickenham not a bad fairy tale
finish
for the greatest rugby player of all
time
and by extension when considering the
greatest sportsman of all time
one who excelled at all forms of
athleticism
fitness skill ingenuity and leadership
he'd be my pick but who'd be yours let
me know in the comments
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider supporting me
you can do that by either joining the 42
club here on youtube by clicking the
join button below
or heading on over to patreon